[Music]
good morning class of 22 transfer
students and Eli Whitney students
welcome to Yale
joining me on this stage to greet you
our president Peter Salovey
Provost Ben Pollock secretary Kim Gough
Cruz Faculty of Arts and Sciences Dean
Tamar Gendler Graduate School Dean Lynn
Cooley athletic director Vicky Chun
Association of Yale alumni executive
director Wei Li Chang officers of the
university the heads and Dean's of the
residential colleges and the deans and
members of the Yale College Dean's
office we extend our warm welcome to the
family members and friends who are here
today it is thanks to your support and
guidance that Yale has the privilege of
hosting these impressive young adults I
am Marvin Chun Dean of Yale College and
I'm extremely pleased to be here today
and my role is Dean one of my job's is
to support president Saliva's mission to
maintain Yale as the research
institution most dedicated to teaching
and learning and what that means for you
students is that I am here to make sure
that you get the best out of this place
in the classroom or out of it before I
address you as Dean though let me first
step out of that role and into another
role that I play here as a professor of
psychology and neuroscience I taught
here for 18 years and in fact this
spring I will be teaching introduction
to psychology I hope you may take it but
I have to confess that according to
course evaluations which I encourage you
to consider when you shop for the many
courses you'll be taking here my class
is apparently overrated
but being the resilient optimist that I
am I actually consider that as a
compliment but as a professor then let
me get down to business and give you
your first quiz a friendly one with no
grading I heard the groan so no grading
gets to get started please pull out the
insert in your program looks like this
okay we're going to focus on the top row
at the top of the program you see four
cards depicted on the top row and
imagine that each card has a letter or
digit each card has a letter or a digit
on each side and you're only seeing one
side on the top row and and I want you
to look at these cards and consider the
following rule if the card has a vowel
on one side then it has an even number
on the other okay okay so if a vowel if
the card has a vowel on one side then it
has an even number on the other and we
wrote down the rule on the bottom of the
cards so here's a quiz which card or
which cards do you need to flip over in
order to determine if the rule is true
or false
and again the rule is if the card has a
vowel on one side then it has an even
number on the other side okay so give
that some thought
all right
um Yale is a very collaborative place
but on most quizzes you're not allowed
to talk to your neighbor but but it's
fine for this morning obviously so
here's the correct answer and I'm thank
you for engaging in the exercise so
here's the correct answer the correct
answer is to pick the a card and the
seven card okay in the original study
only about one out of 25 people got this
correct now while I expect that many
more of you got the right answer I will
not ask you to raise your hand because I
don't want to be bragging on your first
day of school it's not very cool but
please do not feel bad if you didn't get
it right because if this demo demo were
easy or intuitive or obvious
it would not be instructive so let's go
through it together
when people take this quiz most people
correctly pick the a card because if you
turn it over and see an odd number
you've disproven the rule most people
get the a card the D card the second
card is irrelevant and almost no one
picks that one what makes the quiz
interesting is that a lot of people do
pick the four card even though they
don't need to because that card is
irrelevant to the rule people pick it
because it lets them confirm the rule if
they find the vowel on the other side
then they're like oh yeah the rule is
confirmed but this card the four card
does not allow you to prove the rule
false the four card can be flipped over
and show a consonant and the rule would
still hold because we said nothing about
consonants the only card that lets you
test if the rule is false is the seven
card because if you flip that one over
and see a vowel then that would
contradict the rule thank you
it's good so the finding that people
choose the for card and not the seven
card has a technical term and it is
known as confirmation bias and what it
means is that people lean towards
validating their hypotheses rather than
testing if they're wrong
put another way people are drawn to
evidence that confirms their
pre-existing beliefs and so this is
something we want to counter and and you
would think that you know in order to
counter confirmation bias that you would
look all you need to do is look for
information that goes against your
pre-existing views unfortunately it's
not that easy because people don't like
to do that in another study students
were surveyed and divided into two
different groups one that favored
capital punishment another group that
was surveyed to disfavor they were
against capital punishment and so got
these two groups identified them
according to their views and then you
presented both groups with two types of
evidence one type of evidence that
supports that favors capital punishment
as a deterrent to crime and another set
of evidence that shows that capital
punishment is not effective at deterring
crime and you show these both types of
evidence to both groups and you think
okay that's how education is easy that's
how it works and you would think that
seeing both sides would moderate each
subjects view but what the researchers
found was disheartening it was actually
the opposite that instead the students
in each group they started to dig in
they favored the evidence that supported
their view they started to devalue and
discount the evidence that didn't and it
lead left both sides even more polarized
and when they had started that is being
exposed to multiple views is not
sufficient instead one needs to see how
opposing views are also valid so let me
try to demonstrate this point again
using the insert in your program
here's your second exercise of the
morning you're gonna look at the image
in the middle of the insert now okay
take a look at the image in the middle
and name when I say go name out loud
what you see and actually could feel
free to use it whatever language you
want if English is not your first
language there here we go so what do you
see go okay so if you first saw a duck
raise your hand raise your hand if you
saw it duck okay and look around now
raise your hand if you saw a rabbit okay
right almost half of you have different
answers to this demonstration and you
can feel free to see if you can see it
both ways help your partner see it the
other way
okay thank you so everyone sees it both
ways now okay good
this simple demonstration shows a
fundamental principle of psychology
which is that we all experience the
world differently our perceptual
interpretations our memories our
thoughts are all constructs of the mind
and they differ across people even when
you're viewing the same object the same
event or the same evidence so when
exposed to views different from your own
it helps if you can find common ground
with those with whom you disagree
so before you put away your insert let's
take one last look at it this time at
the cartoon on the bottom you see two
armies facing each other and now look at
the army on the bottom and at the front
of it there's a general sitting on a
horse
urging his troops and this is the
cartoon caption there can be no peace
until they renounce their rabbit God and
accept our duck God you can see the
flags and everything
so of course imagine what happens when
the opposing troops realize that they
are serving the same flag and so I would
like to ask you you know what is your
flag what is the flag that you serve and
so please shout out the answer to the
following what's the best university in
the world
I'm trying again what's the best
university in the world alright great
you are all now members of Bulldog
Nation
[Applause]
with the sophomores and juniors and
seniors the alumni faculty and staff and
with each other
here you have common ground an immediate
shared bond that is more than tribal it
goes deeper to the intellectual
curiosity and the commitment to
community that have brought you all here
you have just arrived at a place that
values difference and actively seeks it
out it is how professors and students
find and test knowledge and it is how
the university equips its students
that's you to become leaders and
citizens of the world but here the value
of seeking difference is even more than
that here it is taken as an article of
faith it is the coin of the realm it is
one of the bedrock principles that
governs us in and outside of the
classroom and let me assume that you
came here not just to discover whole
realms of knowledge but also to learn
how to live lives of consequence if that
is true then you have really come to the
right place as you take your first steps
then you will need to become comfortable
with difference not just to accept it or
tolerate it but to insist on it and
you'll find guides everywhere in the
classes you will take the activities you
will join and most of all from the
people sitting around you right now your
peers and classmates all of them are
part of the liberal arts education that
awaits you and what you will find is
that you come from all every possible
walk of life bringing with you every
imaginable talent every experience every
worldview almost half of you identify as
a student of color 12% African American
22% asian-american 15% Hispanic Latin x2
percent Native American about one out of
nine of you are international students
from 57 different countries in this
class you are of all genders and
sexualities about two or three of you
attended public high schools to get here
you have overcome challenges and also
disabilities you
of different religions or none you are
politically liberal conservative
moderate / one out of six of you are
first-generation college students nearly
one out of five of you qualify for Pell
grants for low-income families
Yale is really a great place
[Applause]
speaking of different experiences have
any of you seen the movie a crazy rich
Asians not me of course but but I wanted
to mention that if you want a different
kind of experience gonna see the
lifestyle that's portrayed in the movie
consider a semester abroad at Yale and
us college our sister in Singapore which
is just a really fabulous fun city and
you can get really terrific chilli crab
there but also just an add to you know
consider spending time abroad at any one
of our hundreds of partners around the
world maybe in a spring semester of your
sophomore year when you should not feel
any fear of missing out for the winter
temperatures and two feet of snow on the
ground here so your life at Yale has
just started and in just a few days you
will be enrolling in classes joining
organizations and training with your
teams and as you do that here's what I
hope you will do beware of confirmation
bias when you find yourself simply
validating what you already know if you
are a duck person go find those rabbit
people and find common ground with them
if you are studying Ault duck courses go
find the rabbit courses and see what
they can teach you and when you find
yourself rallying around the duck flag
take a good hard look at the rabbit flag
across the field and the people rallying
around it and remember that you are all
jelly's so you like Whitney students
transfer students members of the class
of 2020 - you all belong to Yale Yale
belongs to you welcome
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
so good morning everyone on behalf of my
colleagues here on stage I extend a warm
welcome to all the family members who
are with us today and to the first
year's
transfer students and eli whitney's
students welcome to Yale
[Applause]
today is a day of pageantry and
excitement many of you bring members of
your extended families to cheer you on
celebrating this milestone with
justifiable pride and just a little
anxiety today is also a day of Yale
traditions you will encounter countless
wonderful rituals here some recent and
some quite old many are steeped in
history yet remain popular even beloved
among jelly's and remember you are now
yelling one of our Yale traditions is
singing an old Sun bright college years
written in the late 19th century it is
our unofficial but widely acknowledged
alma mater you will hear it at many
campus events often sung by the Yale
glee club and other Yale groups and
played by the Yale precision marching
band after football games now I am NOT a
singer actually I'm a bluegrass bass
player but I hope you'll indulge me for
just a moment the seasons come the
seasons go the earth is green or white
with snow but time and change shall not
avail to break the friend
friendships formed at Yale
[Applause]
so thank you for that those those
couplets are some of my favorites from
bright College years about lifelong
friendship and in my experience they are
truthful I suspect they will provide
accurate they will prove accurate for
you as well but it's the songs final
lines popular at alumni gatherings and
always sung with gusto complete with the
waving of handkerchiefs that I want to
use to launch my topic today let us
strive that ever we may let these words
our watch cry be well
upon life's sea we sail for God for
country and for Yale
[Applause]
for God for country and for Yale a
member of the Yale College class of 1881
named Henry Durant wrote this ballot and
the final lines were meant to be a
rallying cry it made sense in those days
to presume as Duran did that most Yale
students shared or at least professed to
share the same God and the same country
most jelly's until recent decades were
white Protestant and American and of
course until fifty years ago in Yale
College they were all men today hell is
a different place from the college to
rand-new
we welcome people from around the world
from every background and from every
walk of life I am proud to be a Yale
graduate I received my PhD in psychology
from Yale in 1986 a hundred years
earlier I may have been less likely to
have been admitted to yell on account of
my background I am Jewish with roots in
Eastern Europe my wife Marta is another
proud yell graduate and she received her
master's degree in public health in 1984
Martha why don't you give a wave here so
people can see who you are
[Applause]
so Marta received her master's in public
health in 1984 her family is from Puerto
Rico now ours our stories are not unique
over the past decades Yale has opened
its doors wider and wider we have
expanded the circle of belonging yet
despite our differences and diversity we
have at least one very important thing
in common we all share Yale no matter
where you are from or who you are or
your path to arriving here now you are
among other things a member of this
community you belong here you are a
citizen of Yale in our country and in
our world today questions about
citizenship and immigration are hotly
contested but at Yale we share none of
this uncertainty about the critical
importance of immigrant and
international students and scholars
the work of the university education and
research requires the free movement of
people and ideas across national
boundaries so on behalf of this
university I advocate for policies that
will allow us to welcome students and
scholars from around the world to our
campus our Yale citizenship however is
not based on national origin our
students across the university hail from
121 countries nor is it based on our
adherence to a certain set of beliefs or
dogma as we bring an enormous range of
viewpoints and perspectives to this
campus instead we are citizens of Yale
because we share a desire to know to
understand and to create we are members
of an academic community dedicated to
Orion v2 meme looks at where ITA's light
and truth we are poets and psychologists
historians and scientists physicians and
Dean's and yet we all share the same
fundamental goal to expand the horizons
of the known world to ask questions that
shake the foundations of knowledge and
to rebuild them again with new Answers
our world is desperate for new ideas and
solutions we need to understand the
human condition and our planet we need
insights into the genome we need
breakthroughs in our ability to fight
disease alleviate suffering and find
justice we need answers to urgent
long-standing questions you will tackle
the
important work at Yale the experiences
you have here will shape the rest of
your lives and you will have
opportunities that most people only
dream of and the cost of Yale education
is a great privilege it comes with
certain obligations I want to speak
today about some of the most important
obligations of Yale citizenship
I will delineate four of them the
responsibilities to be curious
constantly the duty to listen to others
even those whose thoughts you despise
and to exchange ideas freely the
obligation to create a culture of
respect here and the requirement to use
the gifts you have been provided to
serve others and the world so the first
obligation concerns our intellectual and
scholarly work our campus must be a
place conducive to deep study that will
motivate both a lifetime of learning and
the development of character that will
serve you well as Future Leaders Yale
will demand much of you there will be
times when you don't understand an
assignment or struggle with a problem
set you may do poorly on a midterm at
least I hope so those failures as much
as your successes mean you are doing
something right be kind to yourself and
remember that you have come to yell
because you don't know everything
not yet
the faculty will be alongside you as
teachers as mentors you know this is my
33rd year on the ell faculty and I know
that working with students is one of the
great joys of this profession so go to
office hours get to know your professors
they will help you deepen and expand
your expertise but most of all allow
your curiosity to take wing take you in
unexpected directions lead you to new
areas of study practice and discovery I
enrolled in courses in college that I
hadn't planned to take and they changed
the way I see the world now 40 years
later a course in the history of theatre
styles a course in writing poetry a
course in real world applied sociology a
course in geology and Earth Sciences
that involved fascinating fieldwork
make sure you explore the great range
and diversity of academic experiences
available to you here second as citizens
of Yale we are obligated to listen
carefully to others
sometimes this means we must listen to
ideas we find objectionable you don't
have to agree but each of us must enjoy
the opportunity to express thoughts and
opinions we work hard to safeguard this
right on campus I hope you'll have many
opportunities to think deeply and speak
honestly and courageously about
difficult issues during your time here
this course is the heart of the academic
Enterprise so find time find places for
conversation whether in a classroom a
dining hall or on the athletic field
there there are many impediments to
meaningful conversation including
technology now I'm not going to persuade
you to stop texting or tweeting all
together but I urge you to put down your
phones whenever possible
seek out face-to-face interactions we're
happier and our relationships are
stronger when we do just ask anyone who
took psychology and the good life with
Professor Laurie Santos last year they
can tell you the data that support that
observation you will meet people of
remarkable talent remarkable promise and
remarkable integrity here at Yale in the
days and weeks ahead I would urge you to
seek out a wide variety of friends and
associates as I said to last year's
graduating class draw a larger circle to
include people who might look talk act
or think differently from you introduce
yourself to staff members get to know
your neighbors in the city of New Haven
your ability to speak but also to listen
to reach beyond what is familiar and
easy will be one of the great measures
of your time here at Yale third as
citizens of Yale we strive to support a
culture of mutual respect on our campus
to do this we much we must Accord each
person that dignity and recognition they
deserve Claudia Rankine is the Frederick
iseman professor of poetry at Yale in
her powerful work citizen an American
lyric she explores what citizenship and
belonging mean in contemporary America
often she does this by describing
mundane situations I'd like to read you
a passage
in line at the drugstore it's finally
your turn and then it's not as he walks
in front of you and puts his things on
the counter the cashier says sir
she was next when he turns to you
he is truly surprised oh my god I didn't
see you you must be in a hurry
you offer no no no I really didn't see
you so who do we see or not see in our
residential colleges and classrooms in
restaurants on vacation and at work in
our country and in our world who do we
see and who do we look past your lives
at Yale will be busy and full you will
study work volunteer socialize and I
dearly hope sometimes sleep but make
sure you take the time to see the people
around you try to imagine the world
through their eyes bring empathy and
imagination to all that you do I am
counting on each of you together we can
ensure that the Yale community that we
can ensure that Yale is a community
where each person feels valued and
welcomed finally your obligations as
citizens of Yale extend beyond the
campus our alumni are perhaps the
greatest illustration of Yale's
tradition of service 5 Yale graduates
have served as US presidents form as
secretaries of state and 18 as justices
on the US Supreme Court representing
viewpoints across the political
spectrum yellow alumni have served as
heads of state of several other
countries including Italy Mexico Malawi
and South Korea many others have
improved their neighborhoods and cities
as teachers philanthropists and mentors
still others have built businesses and
created jobs for generations our
students and alumni have contributed to
the common good I urge you to carry on
this vital yel tradition for God for
country and for Yale this is still the
promise of bright college years and I
enjoy singing in those words as much as
anyone that even if we worship
differently or not at all
even if we are citizens of different
nations or people without a country we
all share Yale we take pride in our
rights and responsibilities as members
of this community in return for the
great privilege of a Yale education we
look beyond this campus to pursue a
larger purpose to improve the world
today and for future generations this is
what we share in common I'm convinced
that our Yale citizenship is just as
vital today as it was 317 years ago when
this College was founded the world needs
light and truth as much as ever it needs
your leadership and your service it
needs the meaning you bring to the world
and the questions you ask post of all
it needs your best efforts your
successes and your failures as citizens
of Yale sharing a common purpose the
pursuit of knowledge and understanding
let us start today to begin the work we
have come here to do to ask new
questions to listen carefully and speak
honestly to see with new eyes and to
contribute to our communities and our
world most of all leave this hall today
with a commitment in your hearts to be
exemplary citizens of Yale building the
future we all hope to see today as I
look out onto this room I am optimistic
about the future of Yale and the future
of our world
good luck class of 2022
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
my beloved Yale family as we ready
ourselves to step out onto new ground in
this daunting yet inspiring liminal
space of the unknown next we begin a
poignant turn of goodbyes and hellos
then invite laughter tears challenge
choice discovery and pride let us go
forth with deep trust in certain
knowledge that in this place every one
of us is welcome but in this place we
will both stumble and soar that in this
place love surrounds us beauty can
surprise us in this place light and
truth awaits us on this day and every
day forward may all that is holy shine
upon us and tenderly bless our every
breath may we go in
Shalom in Salaam in Shanti may we go in
peace let us speak in
you
[Music]